it's very very important that the
leadership is bottom up because I also
Grew From Within my team and then
started Living in my first management
position which I'm sure happens to
diverse people but for me it was really
like very smooth and
um kind of it opened up the the route to
leadership for me
there's something about living together
with the people in a very like
in in a kind of Harmony and Synergy and
leveling with the people that you're
leading in the most basic and maybe
cliche way but in in a very true soul to
yourself way
um that really
helps you motivate yourself and your
team in a very natural way
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders this
episode is really what the 20
milliliters is all about it's about
leadership meet lilac return the r d
group lead at visita
is a group lead at visita a firm
dedicated to enabling small businesses
and helping entrepreneurs achieve
independence and success she believes in
Social Equity accessibility and reducing
social and gender disparities relock
Rose to management in a fast-paced
startup a few years ago she loved the
action intense collaboration and feeling
of accomplishment she was often the lone
woman in her position and she struggled
to keep her voice and trust her
intuition in difficult situations
bottom-up leadership openness full
partnership and Trust allows to be
authentic
worked as a pastry cook in patisseries
and a Gourmet Catering firm where she
met her partner they have a
seven-year-old daughter and 24 year olds
Ritter welcome to 20 minute leaders how
are you today
thank you very much Michael it's very
nice to be here I'm good thank you
thank you for taking the time to be here
at United I really appreciate it today
your group leader with NBC time engineer
by trade and so today we're going to be
talking about your own career Journey
trajectory growth what you're doing
today some of your you know leadership
mentality and what you've just
discovered about your own leadership
mentality some of the different
challenges presented opportunities
presented and everything in between and
what I want you to know and Linda is
tell me a little bit about your own
career trajectory sort of this The
Guiding North Star that you've had
throughout your career and and what have
been sort of the main milestones for you
over these years
well I think um I think we can split up
that up into two I think when I was a
developer
um I was focusing on one thing and since
I became an engineering manager I'm
focusing on something quite different
because it kind of evolved Through Time
when I just started out I think it was
basically out of curiosity
um the technical side I was always the
kind of technical person I loved math
and physics and coding since I was quite
young and in high school I engaged with
it a lot so it was quite natural for me
to keep on going in that route actually
when I started University I was I was I
didn't know if I should study computers
which was kind of the default for me or
just try something else and I actually
tried out physics and chemistry so I did
my degree in physics in chemistry and
then
um like a year and a half into the
degree I was like okay I'm gonna finish
this because it's a huge Challenge and
they're basically telling you all the
time that you can finish because physics
index so hard and they're like this
prestigious strategy so I finished for
for finishing but it was obvious to me
that it would become like an Academia
person and that's made my life in like
Labs so then I went back to coding which
was my passion and I started my way in
the high-tech industry
um I did a few years of coding
um and then when I stepped up to
management it became a much more diverse
challenge like a human challenge with
people and like a strategic challenge of
how to see the big picture how to
motivate people and move them and it
became something much more complex than
just solving technical problems
what made you make this shift from
developer to now engineering manager
what was the trigger for that was
something that you always you know you
always knew that you want to you want to
be in an engineering manager rather than
a coder because it sounded like you were
also very excited about being very
Hands-On and Technical in your previous
roles
yes that's actually a very good question
I was actually never passionate about
being a leader and being a manager I was
offered during my military service and
in various other positions to step up
and become a team leader or so and I
always
um like pushed it back and was like
sorry that's not me it's not what I want
to do and I never thought of myself as a
kind of a leader person so I was very
surprised to take this too
take this step I was actually a unique
situation in my previous job I started
there when we were like really tiny we
were 30 people only like five developers
and I saw that the company threw like
huge growth like from 30 people when I
left we were like 300 this is my
previous row
and I was very engaged and I knew
um like the code like the back of my
hand and everything was super like
personal and intense and there was a
situation there when my team leader
um stepped aside to a new position and
he also went out for um
um
um so sorry I don't know I'm not sure of
the term in English yeah you have to
have a kid yeah
the vacation yeah
and there was this unique situation
where my boss which was the VPR and they
was like listening they laugh it's your
turn to step up go for it I think you'll
be really good at it and we had this
really good connection I trusted him a
lot and I was like okay I'll give it a
go I'll do this for a few months like
they need me my team needs me the
product needs me I'm super engaged so
I'll just do it for a few months until
we find someone else and then I'll be
done with it
and I just like
fell in love quite instantly with the
role and the responsibility and like the
the
huge rush that it gives you I was very
surprised for the first three months I
was like
very surprised of my enthusiasm in the
job but it was just amazing and so
the the entrance or sort of the thesis
building around your own leadership
style
um what what is you know entering this
entering this position because it sounds
like it was it wasn't a trivial decision
for you it was something that you were
contemplating and then I'm sure that
once the opportunity presented itself
you were thinking about it quite a bit
what type of leader you're going to be
walk me through some of the thought
process of what type of leader you set
out to be as an engineering manager
so that's actually a very good question
that I've been like contemplating and
thinking about ever since the first day
I stayed up to management
um when I was a developer I was used to
like being a minority as a female as a
female but they were other other female
developers and it was like we were able
to
um hire more female developers and I was
slowly less and less alone is is a as a
woman but when stepping up to being an
engineering manager I was looking for a
role model I mean my boss was an amazing
role model and he taught me so many
things but he had his own like Rhythm
and his own kind of way of managing
people and it was very important for me
to find a woman leader to look up to
because I did feel that there was
something different about like the way
um that you lead and of course it's very
like it's also very personal like each
person is very different but there's
also something about being like a female
leader
you have
it's something very soft and not very
easy to put your finger on but there is
something a bit different and I was
really set up to find this role model so
I could learn from someone
and tried that way to find my own way
um so I was very busy looking for this
role model and I didn't really find it I
mean I could find it a bit there in a
bit in another place but there wasn't
like this real
um person that I could really look up to
so it was kind of finding my own way and
I in some ways I'm still finding my own
way in how to
um leads
in a very like honest and true to myself
way
why why so
I I get the the perception of of
difference and and obviously I'm sure
that there's difference in in leadership
mentalities
um perhaps between men and women and
where as you as you continued thinking
about it were you able to put your
finger on some of those differences as
you became more convicted on your own
leadership style and you and you started
also conversing with other female
leaders in Tech
um what are there some some differences
that you're understanding on a higher
level
yes I I think at least for me it's very
very important that the leadership is um
bottom up because I also Grew From
Within my team and then started leading
me in my first management position which
I'm sure happens to diverse people but
for me it was really like very smooth
and
um kind of it opened up the the route to
leadership for me
there's something about leading together
with the people in a very like
in in a kind of Harmony and Synergy and
leveling with the people that you're
leading in the most basic and maybe
cliche way but in in a very true soul to
yourself way
um that really
helps you motivate yourself and your
team in a very natural way
yeah in some ways
um there's some traits that can be
perceived as more feminine more soft or
more mother motherly like
um that when all of your other peers are
men sometimes you just just get tagged
as like you know the more mother like
figure that's more like stuff than
hugging and not firm enough and not you
know what I'm saying it's it's very
again it's it's very hard to put exactly
your fingers right it's something of
that sort
no I understand and I'd have to say that
I may you know if I look at my own
leadership style it's it's very much
similar to what you were mentioning
about sort of this bottoms-up approach
and Trust building Etc so uh so perhaps
uh you know I'm more I'm definitely more
aligned with that I think that part of
the categorization of you know of of the
differences between men and women I
think that you know obviously it's bad
to generalize overall and something that
I that I don't that I don't think it's
helpful because then you get into some
dangerous territory where you're putting
on labels on people and you're quitting
expectations that aren't necessarily
true I mean every person is individual
whether they're men men women or
whatever and and anybody can be a
fantastic leader and um you know some
men can be feminine and some family some
women can be masculine and it's all it's
all the said and and what I'm curious
about your your experience is that as
you're now as female leader that in
today's world statistically speaking is
still a minority the in a leadership
setting
what what what insights do you have
about sort of this this dissonance
between sort of this overall mission
that all of us have in in sort of
equalizing the playing field and
creating equal opportunities regardless
of your background or your gender versus
now you're actually experiencing
firsthand so what what insights are you
coming into this conversation with now
that you've had some mileage as a female
leader in this position
yeah
um that's a good question
I think I'm gonna quote
um the CEO and founder of the company
I'm working for now visita
um Levy I read an um an interview that
he did once I think in the very early
stages of the company and he said
something very simple there that really
like got to me
he said that one of the first tires he
did for the man for a very senior
management position
um was a woman
um and he said once you hire one senior
manager that's a woman The Other Woman
will follow because they would just feel
more comfortable
and this is like it's very simple but
it's true once you create an actual
diverse place of of work that it comes
from the management and all the way down
the people the minorities will feel more
comfortable coming to interview will
feel more comfortable in the interview
process and also feel more comfortable
coming to work every day
it's basically as simple as that
interesting interesting and so
you know if we try to sort of reverse
engineer Bottoms Up approach why why
that creates such a strong impact what's
your
what's your rationale for that
what do you mean why does why the wild
you know bringing on a female senior
leadership role in the beginning why is
that create sort of this exponential
effect uh throughout the growth of the
company that makes it much more viable
for for more female talent to join
because I think
um as a woman you do feel more
comfortable being interviewed at least
for some of the process you're always
interfering with three or four people
throughout the process when you're
um interviewing for uh hide the company
that's usually the how it works so if at
least one or two of them is a woman
you feel more representative more
represented and you feel more
comfortable to like be yourself and show
out your technical skills or your
leadership skills or just Who You Are
interesting interesting so transitioning
more again to your your personal sort of
passion for engineering leadership and
and
um and in in Engineering in general you
know what what are some things that you
found very helpful in your own growth as
a leader as your as you're managing a
group now within VC car so you know as
you if you look sort of at your own
growth as a leader now and your insights
to what allows you to build a distrust
with the people you're working with and
be an effective leader in the
engineering space What are some things
that that if you were to talk to some
other leaders that are starting out now
their own first step into engineering
leadership what are some things that are
perhaps not trivial that you are now
looking back that you would tell
yourself
um so I think
the two things that really help you
um
be a good leader and connect with the
people that you're leading is when
you're getting to know a person that is
part of your team that you're leading
you need to look at them
um in two aspects first of all you need
to look at that person and get to know
them as much as possible and understand
what makes them kick
what's their passion like is are they
super technical and they just want
technical challenges are they more of a
business kind of
minded developer what what gets them
like what gets them motivated what gets
them excited I love seeing my developers
and my team getting excited that's like
the most that that gets me excited
so
look at that person and try and
understand
with them or from them what is that
thing that makes them kick and make sure
they have that those sort of tasks in
their week months next half your next
year make sure they have those tasks
and the other thing is the the coupling
between two people or between teams like
make sure that a developer
is coupled with another developer say on
some kind of big task or in the team
that would make them shine
and respect their shine on each other
you know like say there's this
um highly technical person but they're a
bit
and under confident although they're
super smart and and an amazing amazing
technically and group them with maybe a
more Junior person
that that is confident and that's very
passionate and that's like good with
connecting to the rest of the team and
that coupling can bring the best out of
these two people and actually help them
step up and
bring the best out of them and advance
in their career path
so you're so so you see part of your
role is to identify what relationships
to build within the workplace and and
what Partnerships they create so that
people will help each other Rise and
strengthen each other and it's less of
an individual manager type relationship
it's individual individual and then
individual manager that that individual
individual piece is is an important one
from your perspective
it's amazing I've seen like I've seen so
many good things come out of people with
the right pairing it's not always a pair
it can be also a trio or just a small
team of like three four developers but
the interaction is
it's priceless
interesting and so that process do
usually do
um how do you get that dating to work
within the workplace how do you find how
do you identify whether a match will be
a successful one
yeah that's that's a good question you
need to look in my last space because I
was there for so long and I
um near all my developers very well
every time a new developer came into the
team
um or to the group
I would usually try and detect
like what would be the first good
um task for this new person and who they
should do it which
uh and then I would like play around
with it a bit and then in the bigger
features down the road when I got to
know this person and I already knew all
of the other developers because I was
there for so long it was just it it
would be kind of clear and everything
would just fall into place but you do
you really need to like know the people
in order to
do that and you also can just try an
error
so if you had to summarize
um what do you enjoy most about what you
do today you know well where do you get
your own personal passion and
satisfaction in your day-to-day where is
that stemming from for you
I think it's two-sided
uh on the one hand I love
seeing the big picture I love seeing how
the product that we are developing as a
development group
meets our clients and our customers in
the field and brings value I love
talking with our customers to see how
they're using the product and to
understand the business uh behind of it
so like the business product development
cycle is fascinating to me
and on the other side I love getting my
developments my developers engaged into
that cycle and also seeing how that
brings the best out of them and also
helps Advance their career because they
can look at the big picture and like
see how they Advanced Within that big
picture
I love it and I have to say that
throughout this whole through throughout
this whole um episode you know I think
what really resonate is how much more
passion you are about what are you doing
how how intentional you are about
everything that you're doing and you
know you it sounds like you're it's not
just about you know your own trajectory
it's also about the growth of your team
and how do you create a healthy balance
between a healthy team that is able to
not only support itself but also support
you know support each other support you
you support them and it sounds like that
that relationship building is something
that is very fundamental to your own
leadership style and so it's very it's
first of all it's very refreshing to
have that mindset uh and to hear about
it and it's very inspiring as they
um as somebody who might like myself why
I hope I aspire to be a good leader in
anything that I do so this is definitely
something that I'm going to be taking
with me and lilas I really want to you
know thank you for your time for your
effort your energy and this was a great
episode and I can't wait to share this
with friends family and everybody around
so thank you again for taking the time
best of luck with
um with visita and you as an engineering
manager and I'm sure that there's so
many more incredible things you'll do so
thank you very very much for everything
and stay safe and thank you Michael for
a time it was really really nice to meet
you and I'm really glad that my words
like got to you resonated in in that way
foreign